sometimes I believe my fans don't even
notice when I'm gone if I have things
accumulated like content but I've done
that I've went into a rant for a month
without any without anyone knowing yes
let's talk about the secret life of lily
ponds your new YouTube documentary
premiering May 19th on YouTube my
deepest darkest secret is that I have
OCD I just had to touch everything
everything and if I didn't touch
everything like I thought my family was
in the diet lately I want to just give
you a big hug I had no idea that you
were struggling with any of these things
I see what the world sees a funny
beautiful bubbly girl who's just always
laughing and smiling and to know that
you're going through so much stuff my
heart goes out to you why expose your
story to the world I'm someone that has
always tried to be like someone else on
social media like super positive
everything's perfect life I thought it
was about time now that I'm not really
ashamed and embarrassed I'm having OCD
that I was I thought it was time to let
the world see my vulnerable side because
I had never had you know I never and I
feel like you know I owe it to my fans
as well because they've always been so
vulnerable to me and I'm worried and
they're just gonna be like you yet I'm
just you know Kenneth yeah I told him
when someone that you admire has it has
a condition that you have it just pushes
you inspires you it gives hope and then
you're not alone I feel like something
right now especially that we all need
can you just kind of break down exactly
what is OCD and what sort of compulsions
do you actually suffer from there are
thoughts and there's actions there are
things that you don't want to do but
your brain and your thoughts are telling
you to do it
what I have is mostly thoughts and an
act and I do a lot of actions because of
the thoughts they do things in numbers I
do things in three I do a lot of
touching a lot of checking I talked to
someone I repeat myself three times but
they don't notice I touch something in
three times sometimes I even get nervous
when I when I let's say I do something
that's two times and I'm just like I
need to go back and no one really knows
you know three times
everything is so calculated it's insane
and then it comes with thoughts you know
I have fear if I don't do this three
times something Bad's gonna happen and
you really really truly believe it it's
it's you know some people it's not much
it's not normal you know because
you I know for a fact that it is nothing
bad can happen but the feeling is still
there then you should leave it like it
just it's hard y3 is there a reason for
that exact number and what are those bad
thoughts that you think I connect it to
me to religion because He is God Jesus
in the Holy Spirit I went to a Catholic
school
when you go to Catholic school like
maybe I think about time I got obsessed
with something that had to do with three
and the Holy Trinity I remember that and
then ever since that I've been doing
things with me just because I'm scared
that God would punish me and it's I mean
it sounds really bad but like you truly
the people that have us a truly of
course I mean what do you think you'll
be punished with I think that something
Bad's gonna happen like I'm gonna have a
bad day I'm gonna I'm gonna lose someone
my mom I'm very lucky because I've been
working with my therapist for a very
long time and I can tell you that when I
was little I couldn't move I was stuck
in one place I couldn't move in my dad
had to carry me around so now what do
you feel it's mostly this is just to
ease this side one time I I didn't even
make it to an event like why don't you
come to this event why don't you come
around she's like I don't know how to
explain this but I was stuck in the
bathroom and I couldn't get out the pain
of of OCD for me it's like let's say you
locked a baby in the car and you seemed
they're crying
and you can't open it that's how bad the
feelings I went to a parent that send me
and I met a lot of kids I have different
types of CDs you know it's it's just
like some some people actually like are
afraid to go outside or afraid to be
contaminated and one of my friends you
know she would wash her child a baby in
for a carton she was so afraid you
mentioned just now in a little story but
you didn't make it to an event because
you're in the bathroom crying with your
line of work
I mean Leila you're expected at award
shows and photo shoots and all sorts of
things like that how has this mental
health issue that you're going through
how does it an impact your career it is
in fact in my career and actually other
ways that are positive like I'm obsessed
with hard-working I'm obsessed with
making videos so people are like wow she
makes so many videos and I'm just like
yep because I can't stop I stop enemy
like no I three videos a day and if I
stopped I feel like my cacao is gonna be
deleted the next day something bad is
gonna happen
so people were like wow she's such a
hardworking person I got a look at this
I mean I'm just like yeah you know it
has to do with OCD - what happens if you
go into a panic situation and you're
expected to go do something maybe on
like live TV I've had meltdowns beyond
so does it look like it's just like me
just asking for help like me just being
like I can't control this I can't manage
this I don't know what to do we usually
have a wiggle break you know because I
do have a lot of tics as well that's
right and you know sometimes I try to
hide I do them but I do it in things
like in a way that you can't see them
but sometimes I'm just gonna go with
like a wiggle break I need to do them
quickly you know like let's say if I'm
doing it right now you with my hand you
won't see it but sometimes I just wanna
you know like just do it
you know that happens in interview
sometimes actually do them in interviews
but nobody knows because I'm so good my
therapist said I'm so good at hiding but
if I tell you what they are you will
you'll notice what was it like watching
all of that me seem that it's just and
well was it that bad but I remember in
that moment it was you know and it's
crazy because when you're obsessing when
you have OCD you don't even realize some
things you do you don't how do you
manage it I know that you're very close
with your therapist but what are the
things that you have to do to get
yourself in a place where you're like
calm cool and collected we do things
like exposures right exposures means
that you go out out and actually test
your OCD so I was obsessed with when
people have like a little bit of food
left you know people might be like oh
you got something there right but I
would be like I don't care like iswhat's
Oh stranger like can you please like
take this off now like what I would do
it I would go to a place and my
therapist got that would put sauce on
her face and she would just talk to me
for a whole hour and that's an exposure
and I'd be like
shaking and like that couldn't tell her
to take it off that's an explosion you
know
OCD you help it by making it feel
uncomfortable so you do these exercises
you said you spent time on a ranch yeah
when did you go do that I've been doing
that for like a lot of times like
sometimes like with my fans don't even
notice when I'm gone cuz I have things
accumulated like content but I'm done
that I've been into a ranch for a month
without anyone knowing yeah how often
are you going and what makes you decide
to pick up the phone and say hey guys I
got it when it's really bad or when I
feel like there's a big project coming
that might trigger a lot of my stuff I
do I go there to prepare it myself well
I mean Laila you have a big project
coming out and I can't go to the bank
but I'm talking every day I have
sessions is doing interviews and all of
this like promotion is that triggering
yeah of course how do you flirt with
that I like this topic a lot you know
and it calms me down I'm focused
definitely focused I mean I did some
takes while I'm talking to you like what
have you been doing during this
interview have you noticed I've been
doing this under what you will never
notice you know I knew this was a very
private struggle that you've been going
through your whole life who knew other
than your mom and dad that this is
something that you're experiencing all
my friends like from back when I was
like young do your collaborators know
like just Towanda does Hannah know
because they're making content with you
constant and it's cool that they're all
in the documentary but with that the
first time that they found out or they
knew long time ago Hannah and Antwon
have known I even visit me in the ranch
it's awesome stuff like I would do God
they would have to make them like do
stuff like for example like throw a pen
incorrectly or like how I wouldn't want
to throw a pen on the floor you know she
threw it in a bad way you know not a
perfect way there's no perfect way to
throw a pen but like you know I had that
obsession of like two independent
thinking about throwing and figure it
out and she threw it and I didn't and I
couldn't pick it up you know like and
then they see that and they're just like
wow like it's just like something's
taking over
you